hello everyone seems like it's everyone
who want to be here right now
um my name is
a data scientist from kwenturi Contour
is a company uh which is main focus on
the uh software development data
engineering and Engineering in life
science domain informatics and
everything and today I want to introduce
you how we work with teachers
electronical Health Data and how we
apply different uh complicated uh neural
networks and models more generally do
these specific
data and here's our journey and I will
start from what is General in political
sales records and how we adopt or LP
methods to work with these type types
data and after that we will just discuss
how we could improve it and to work with
it generally
okay uh what is etras in general well
suppose that everyone goes to doctor and
you know that nowadays all their work is
digitalized and they put out data about
you in the databases and usually there
looks like well some IDs the general
name and the vocabulary for this exact
type data well it could be the snomad
ICD ICD-10 is most common and that is
how mostly imagine this data is
structured after that it's stored in a
very huge and very big databases usually
they are not open for everyone but if
you are a scientist you could ask for
majority of them well for example if you
want to work with them I recommend UK
buy a bank it's a very huge very big
data set based on the data from United
Kingdom I suppose that half a million of
people for 10 years so a lot of
different data but but before you will
work with it I recommend you to think
about the this exact date what is
consists of and how to work with it well
at first we should imagine that the
variety this data is enormous and if
we'll speak about only the conditions in
ICD-10 I suppose it would be 16
000 of unique conditions and also you
will work with measurements drugs well
medications and different operations
which are done with patients so that is
why we need to understand how to work
with these huge enormous amount of
different unique features and the first
look well you may think that okay I will
take the basic data scientist methods
like
feature importance or for example any
kind of dimensional introduction a
simple one pce whatever and I will use
it for my purposes I'll take the best or
the latest space but unfortunately it's
you may find that it's super complex to
work with this data because it
have a lot of different errors and
outliers and well you need to prepare it
properly and I'll tell you about well a
small amount of different problems you
may find this data just for you to be
prepared uh one of them is that all this
data is
manually uh
obtained from doctors or some medical
services and that's why there are a lot
of mistakes will just made by hand well
measurements units
all kinds of mistakes like well it
should be 10 times less but the newers
will put this data and it's sometimes a
very complicated to find where it's the
real mistake or it's just an outlier but
natural outlayer and well here will be
several distributions of uh for
different features and it sometimes uh
not always how to work with them well
for example here if I remember it should
be well uh Kim clubbin well diglicated
one which is widespread to diagnose the
diabetes and here you can see that there
are a lot of zeros well just in the
beginning well there is a small
distribution
I suppose that it should be just
mistakes in the units and after that you
see that that is not normally
distributed data but in some kind of
combination of different distributions
so
that is why it's a little bit
complicated to work with it and
more even if you see that the
distribution is okay it could be
outliers and mistakes inside one person
well for example it's normal for a
man to have weighed 100 pounds well 200
pounds sometimes but if you see that
this person was uh I don't know 100 and
after the 200 something is not something
is not okay and you try I should utilize
some methods to find these Samplers so
why I want to say that this data is the
worst type of data you may imagine well
because it's made of humans and it's a
very special because for some cases you
will understand that it's a mistake only
you have some medical education or you
have the specialist in your team who
could say that okay it's not something
right and mathematical methods usually
not work properly if you're not in the
contact with people who are aware how
and why it should be used so I highly
recommend if you have the project like
that find a business analyst or some
consultant from medical sphere or people
should be well in your team or data
scientists should be deeply dived into
the domain well because
sometimes it's complicated and sometimes
well you may take different algorithms
to find outliers to find uh nuns or
whatever and it will not work properly
yes uh that is
and one more thing that we could imagine
thinking about it that this data is a
super non-linear and uh
well if you think that okay we could try
to utilize the standard approaches to
work with data well the kind of uh for
example we may try to obtain clusters
with some human practice knee or
whatever but
it may be not
insightful because
the problem is that this data is made by
doctors and doctors are very
conservative and if you want to find the
new data you should utilize some
non-linear and highly non-linear
algorithms which could provide you with
some new insights non-trivial results
and that is why we start thinking about
the bird model well I suppose that most
of the people who work in data science
and NLP especially are aware about this
Transformer and it's widely used in a
variety of obligations to the NLP but
the structure of this model and the idea
Society could be used not only for this
type of data but also for our for
example for eaters at one of the points
I want to we'll just Express today is
that you may use different approaches
from different spheres of the data
science and machine learning and to
apply them to a non-standard variance of
data but how we could use the language
model for features and the answer is we
need to construct language and this
language will consist of the Wizards the
concept the features and people inside
it and for example here is a diagram
which was proposed by the people what
Clips link well it's a niche paper
where they propose how we could
construct this language well we'll just
build tokens we should be a lot of
sentences where you have the patient ID
you have the each token will be a visit
with some conditions and any kind of
indications that were taken and that is
how you will obtain your language the
language will consist of sentences and
sentences is the Wizards which have the
strong positional connection to what
kind of features we try to use and
well there are some problems with it
obviously well because if we'll just
take this kind of data it would obtain
all the well cones from this day table
because it's very sparse you will never
have the
um regular regularly Wizards and
sometimes even well I have seen that it
was two visits for one person and they
were separated but 10 years but the
features were super connected inside it
and any kind of neural network would say
okay I think that we should utilize it
and to make some predictions based on
this connection which is obviously not
sensible at all and we try to find the
new ways how we could modify this kind
of language and the answer is that we
could try to utilize the positional
recording and we will obtain more
temporality inside this tokens when we
have the one by one Wizards for each
person with all conditions and
positionally encoded and we obtain these
kind of vectors which are more
robust for uh different
outliers and mistakes inside data and on
the other hand it helps us to be
consistent of what and how we do with
this data generally speaking the bird
except the tokens inside is just the
same the same word we are using filter
language models
and we trained it on the standard
variants like MLM and speed well mask
language model well you get rid of one
part well if it centers one word and
here in what in our case would be one
token and NASA next samples prediction
well it's just we try to find what would
be the next token and uh surprisingly it
was not our purpose but we obtained the
model which could predict what be the
next visit of your patient in clinic and
it's uh what not the main purpose of our
project but it's very interesting that
we used it and
really you could try to do it with all
kinds of data if you imagine just invent
this kind of language and to use this
method
um
and more uh unfortunately the classical
method of bird well it gives the good
results but we need it to obtain more
information and some more variants and
we come to the Siamese bird as bird well
which
seems like more
appliable to our exact problems but the
other point is that
we should map the data well if you are
most familiarable Siamese bird is when
you have some kind of
understanding of the meaning inside the
sentences like it would be a relational
or it will be neutral a question
whatever and here we need to invent how
we'll connect the token sentences in our
own language and the first idea was that
we'll say okay we'll construct it like
that we have the sentence which is
consists of ingredients and the
medications which were taken by a
patient and try to find what will be the
list of conditions this person should
have and that works but unfortunately
you could not do it on a very large
scale because a lot of hand work and
it's not super obvious how to do it so I
suppose that this work will become
continued but
we'll see
and finally uh what we have seen when
our model is trained uh from our kind of
language we have this latent space which
represent people or conditions connected
to each other and in this embedding
space well we just simply just as as
simple as usual latent space you could
find the insights of how conditions are
connected for example and you could make
the graph of connections between
different diseases and to make a
classification which is natural not
artificial like it's usually do and
um
and that is well once again something
would you could find from this model but
just uh this graph of different
connections uh we in our work mostly
looked at the connections between
different patients to find the special
groups of people which are needed to be
treated differently
but as we know well it was well a very
beautiful representation well a few
hours ago about the explanation and the
exploratory Ai and I could say that in
Healthcare doctors they love
explanations they could not say that
okay we have a black box which gives you
their results and we always need to
obtain some kind of explanation
attention mechanism which is inside the
Transformer the bird we use could be
used for these purposes but if we have a
very complicated model well as big it is
and it's hard to use it straightforward
and sometimes it's almost impossible and
you always will need some additional
techniques on the next step when you for
example you obtain your embedding space
and here for example want to find some
special groups of people you could
utilize any kind of algorithm for
plastering obtain clusters and after
that you have the chart align what you
like and to find the interpretation of
each group of people and that is device
vital part of each experiment at each
project in the medical sphere and the
healthcare that you will need to have
this intractable
diagrams they are also complicated and
some say that they are not absolutely
obvious to doctors for example but they
are much better comparing just to model
which is Black Box
and
um
and I suppose that that it is for right
now and well some
there are some main ideas we have to do
that reversed we could obtain a good
model which is never without light to
your kind of data but you could invent a
new method well you could just take
something from the computer vision from
the NLP whatever and apply it to you to
your data but be careful you need to
understand your data and your domain and
everything
and
as a sequences well the second point is
deep knowledge in the domain and the
specialist who could help you but is a
key to make the outcomes valuable for a
customer or for your project whatever
and also the next is that we need to
obtain the validation and if you want to
provide answers and you could validate
them and obtain the results but it's
good if not you try it you need to find
how you could
interpret the results and
um
well and finally yes remember that the
data could be a very non-qualified and
you need to do a lot of things just to
overcome these limitations sometimes
with the help of someone or we'll just
deep down yourself
well
that is all well I suppose for right now
I was not very accurate well not
accurate well I'm not deep dive into the
technical details and if you want you
could ask me about it
well but it's for General overview well
thank you very much well questions
foreign
yes
well it depends but if you will try to
use this model in production for any
kind of Professional Medical
recommendation for example we have
trained our model and we could predict
the next step yes you will have need to
go to the FDA for example United States
to obtain license and there is well
evidence is that it's possible so you
could do it and you should provide well
it would work like a medical device so
you will need to have you'll need
well several stages of uh trials medical
trials to prove that it works
well
well
in some countries maybe not well uh
generally it's a new domain well if
we'll speak about the health care and
the legal entities who could not uh well
make the laws right now to well provide
for example in Russia uh we recently
maybe one well listen one year ago we
obtained a new law which uh makes
everyone who wants to insert the
recommendation they call it
recommendational systems into the
telemedicine and all that whatever you
need to obtain the license and to prove
that it works like a medical device and
there is a term well the special asset
for electronical medical system
something kind of and you could go
through it well with this stuff
but it's complicated you'll for sure
need the some lawyers and specialists in
this field well and the cleaning of
Doctor Who will
help you with it because well uh while
we work well not on this project but
previously I've worked with the
different institutions in Russia and
sometimes you'll need a person who will
be a Authority who could help you to go
through this all medical stuff because
sometimes people but it's a new domain
and they will say okay this is strange
we don't understand it we don't
understand what we need to do well in
that states it's easier well for example
uh there is a tool called ad well which
is licensed in Europe and you could just
enter your conditions what is going on
with you and they will say Okay possibly
you have this kind of disease and go to
that kind of doctor and they have the
license on the European Union well
okay thank you
thank you okay thank you